NARRATOR: Like Yasuhiro Kubo
here, going for a Guinness
world record title.
He'll be free falling
from around 10,000 feet
and attempting to catch
up with his parachute
attached to this canister.
The record is determined by how
long he waits before jumping.
At 50 seconds
later, off he goes.
[music playing]
Well, that was a relief--
and a world record.
Free falling without a
parachute is one of the most
dangerous stunts imaginable.
Do not even consider considering
to consider to do it, ever.
Especially when even regular
skydivers have their off days.
A little help please, bro?
Go on, you can do it.
Go on.
Great, thank you.
All right, so how does a
skydiver fall fast enough
to catch up with
a parachute thrown
out nearly a minute beforehand?
Well, to find out, we need
to brush up on terminal
velocity and air resistance.
As an object falls, it
collides with trillions
of tiny air molecules,
resulting in air resistance.
As the object accelerates, the
air resistance acting on it
increases until it matches the
force of the object's weight.
It's now at terminal
velocity, the maximum speed
it could fall.
A larger surface area
increases air resistance,
and so decreases
terminal velocity.
A smaller surface area
decreases air resistance,
and so increases
terminal velocity.
A skydiver in spread
eagle position
hits terminal velocity
around 120 miles an hour
after about 12 seconds.
But for Yasuhiro to
catch up with his chute,
that is just too slow.
So which of our
wannabe record breakers
has remembered how we speed
up our terminal velocity?
Not these ones.
That is the complete opposite.
Their raft has a
large surface area,
thereby increasing
air resistance
and slowing them down.
OK, anyone else?
Yeah, that's it.
Going upside down and
reducing his surface area
decreases air resistance and
increases terminal velocity.
Trouble is-- oh, whoa,
it's very hard to control.
Oh, that guy upside down, too?
Yes, he was.
Once he's caught
up with his chute,
Yasuhiro needed to steer himself
into position to grab it.
How did he do that?
Well, skydivers can also use
air resistance to maneuver.
For example, by
adjusting his body shape,
this guy deflects flex
more air backwards,
which pushes him forwards.
Bullseye?
Somehow, all of our
high flyers were fine,
but I think we should leave
the record to Yasuhiro.